في منطقه المرج سنزور واحده من الجمعيات
الخيريه التي تقوم على خدمه اهل المنطقه
انا عندي جمعيه بتقوم على رعايه الايتام
والمحتاجين والفقراء كشف علاج اشاعات
عمليات
فوق ده فوق ده طبعا تجهيز عرايس ايتام وكل
ده طبعا خلاف كده شنط سلع شنط لرمضان
اغذيه بتقوم برضو على ملابس تمام ولكن كل
ده بيقوم على
التبرعات طبعا مثل غالبيه الجمعيات
الخيريه تعتمد جمعيه مستقبل السعاده على
تبرعات اهل الخير في تقديم خدماتها لاهالي
منطقه المرج فما الذي حدث لمثل هذه
التبرعات بعدما تراجعت قيمه الجنيه امام
الدولار اكيد طبعا هي انا لو عندي هنقول
مثلا كان بيجيني تبرعات وليكن 80% فالان
ده ما بقاش موجود ممكن نقول 20% بقى موجود
خصوصا انا ما عنديش اي امدادات خارجيه
ما عنديش مثلا متبرعين كفايه ممكن يكونوا
ما تخطوش عدد الايد الواحده